immenses espoirs suscités hier à vienne
à la conférence internationale sur le
sida des chercheurs ont présenté un gel
microbicide qui réduirait de 50 % les
risques de contamination par le vih
un moyen de prévention qui s'adresse aux
femmes florence bukiya christophe vignal
ce gel vaginal contient 1% de tenofovir
un médicament déjà largement utilisé
dans le traitement du sida
deux ans et demi durant 843 femmes l'ont
testé elles vivent dans le natal en
afrique du sud un état dans lequel une
femme sur deux passes et 24 ans est
séropositif nous avons conseillé aux
femmes d'utiliser le gel 12 heures avant
une relation sexuelle est encore douze
heures après la relation mais pas plus
de deux applications par jour appliquée
nous avons constaté 39 % de risques
d'infection et jusqu'à 51%
si le gel est bien utilisé loin de
concurrencer le préservatif en matière
d'efficacité
ce gel microbicide pourrait tout de même
permettre aux femmes de prendre en main
leur propre protection
surtout dans les pays du sud
l'utilisation du préservatif reste une
affaire d'hommes et dans les pays du
nord aussi le gel pourrait aider un
certain nombre de femmes ce sont les
femmes qui pour diverses raisons ne
peuvent pas utiliser des préservatifs
donc les femmes qui sont soient
contraintes par leur mari avoir des
rapports non protégés ou des femmes dont
le métier la prostitution et qui sont
contraintes par leur client à ne pas
utiliser de préservatif depuis vingt ans
les recherches sur les gels microbicides
ont toutes échoué cette fois des
scientifiques du monde entier commencent
à y croire